[Musik]
dabei ist luca und meine damen und
herren jetzt schon ich habe mir ein
hemdchen angezogen habe ich hier ein
bisschen schick gemacht denn wir
reagieren heute auf ein lied was mir
dass es gerade einfach nur schwarz wie
reagieren heute zusammen auf einen lied
das mir gewidmet wurde was über mich
handelt es heißt million stecker
contractors teil das lied hat ganze 78
aufrufe und vier bewertungen ich meinen
nicht alles was nicht bekannt ist muss
auch scheiße sein oder dem video gibts
tatsächlich aus 2 kommentare die hawks
kinder die gehen heftig ins recht
ja das war es mehr kommentare
gibt es da nicht allerdings würde ich
sagen bevor ich hier noch lange drum rum
lager wir schauen uns jetzt mal direkt
das video an mit an beginn des neuen
millenniums hätte unsere schöne welt wie
wir sie kennen auseinanderfallen sollen
von den menschen tieren und pflanzen die
diesen planeten einst bewohnten wäre nur
schutt und asche übrig geblieben
also das geht wirklich los und so wird
sich der song wahrscheinlich da noch
anhören jedoch gab es einen krieger der
sich dem schicksal entgegenstellte und
unsere düstere zukunft rettete sein name
war luca auch bekannt als horn crafter
das ist das intro und jetzt schauen wir
mal was der song so für uns bereithält
goldkette oder irgendeine andere kette
mit einem smiley dran super-g photoshop
million stecker kontrast ist ja der
titel okay jetzt kommt ein anderer beat
gerade
[Musik]
ich hab mir zu beginnen weil die
witterung wirklich gedacht hey da kommt
so ein typisches lied irgendwie so ich
sehe der retter der die düstere welt
rettet und hört wie es weitergeht
[Musik]
ich dachte ich habe außer sich auf pause
gedrückt aber im lied war einfach so
eine zwei sekunden pause also ich weiß
nicht was er mit diesen die plätz wecken
will muss das natürlich noch zu ende an
das ist ja noch vier minuten vier
minuten geht das loch juden haben wir
auf jeden fall die lyrics die sind auf
jeden fall ganz schön lang
wir dürfen uns gar nicht anschauen wir
müssen es erstmal das liegt noch zu ende
anhören
hier nicht immer so sich die wand werfen
kann
doch luca ist und gewinne zusammen mit
ihr keine chance
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wow ich dachte dass es nach rabat nicht
noch schlimmer werden kann
[Musik]
wie bitte du gehst auf den strich oder
du kannst du aus als wäre es jetzt keine
bleibt
oh mein gott
also ich wusste ja schon immer dass
meine community heftig am arsch ist so
aber so krass
das hätte ich mir nicht mehr in meinen
kühnsten träumen vorstellen können die
abonnenten
ich habe mich wirklich ein hemd
angezogen weil
ja das
[Musik]
teilweise
ich halt nicht mehr was er sagt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
was ist uns mitteilen
also verstehst bitte nicht falsch lieber
million stecker ich begrüße es total
dass du so was gemacht hast und ich
werde so etwas auf keinen fall deswegen
weil ich weiß dass leute sowas für mich
machen
falls ihr euch übrigens wundert warum
ich teilweise rumhüpfen ich habe mir so
ein gymnastikball gekauft auf dem ich
jetzt immer meine videos auf und da kann
ich so
eigentlich brauche ich mich gar nicht
mehr wundern warum eine community so was
für mich macht
jo jo jo brinkhaus von nokia du bist
nicht super
daumen hoch da lassen an der stelle mich
das heutige video ist allerdings auch
beenden meine damen und herren wenn euch
meine reaktion auf diesen contractors
teil gefallen hat dass gamer ein like da
vielleicht habt ihr ja auch ins heim für
mich gemacht das könnt ihr immer gerne
in die kommentare schreiben und sonst
kommt jetzt das outro
[Musik]
ein